six locations in two days as their
prince of Wales launches his life's
ambition a plan to end homelessness I
first visited homeless shelter when I
was 11 with my mother
the visits we made together left a deep
and Lasting Impression over the next
five years we have a unique opportunity
to develop Innovative new Solutions and
scale their tangible impact
this will inspire belief throughout the
UK and beyond that homelessness can be
ended for good
Newport in South Wales is one of the six
areas targeted by the project
stuck in a cycle of temporary housing
Wayne's been homeless here for over a
decade nearly eight years clean and but
I'm still struggling with a homelessness
regarding to get the flat so basically
I'm in a pod it's a like a shipping
container I'm just waiting on the
council name to basically move me
forward to get a my own property
basically and that's what I'm hopefully
get a full-time job
all Wayne wants is a home but it's years
away and after so long waiting he
doesn't think homelessness will ever end
look how long it's been trying to get a
bit of homelessness no no offense I
don't think we'll ever go into
homelessness but I wish we could but
it's not going to happen
with well-known faces the prince's
project will collaborate and convene to
find local solutions to end homelessness
a bold pledge say some given his
position of enormous privilege
Prince William is a huge landowner he
has multiple homes is he really the
right person to be standing there and
saying I can solve homelessness
who's the right person to solve and end
homelessness we've all got to do it he's
put his hand up and he said look I'm
committing to to play my part you could
you could make a real gesture imagine
giving over a house giving over a palace
that really wouldn't make a dent into
the situation we need structural
systemic change
it is a political issue for a prince who
sits above politics but he says it's not
about policy just action and positive
change Laura bundock Sky News Newport